so i'll speak about how quantum the ua
machine is
uh so you know this is really a burning
question of the day
most of you probably remember that over
the last year there has been a lot of
excitement
and debate about the dua machines and
there are i think there are two
encouraging sides to this uh all this
controversy
one encouraging side is that it really
shows that there's a lot of excitement
and energy out there about this idea of
quantum computing
not just from the scientific community
but from the general public so if you go
to the news website
they talk about ua you see all these
people all these different people
entrepreneurs you know business people
students reporters of course
genuinely excited about this new
potential
for this new field and as researchers
working in this field is something we
should be really excited about
and the the other encouraging side is
that last year
there has been a lot of scientific
efforts to really understand the nature
of
the tv machines namely whether they're
really performing something
truly quantum mechanical or they reduce
some kind of classical description
okay so um
of course in terms of showing that the
ua machine is quantum
the most direct way to show that would
be to demonstrate some kind of speeder
but as sergio told us as of now it seems
that there is no speed up
so we focus our attention on the next
immediate question which is
whether the machine is at least
employing some kind of non-trivial
quantum effects
which could be a basis for uh prospects
for a future sphere
but unfortunately i think it's also true
that last year there has been a lot of
confusion
um unnecessary confusion because
whenever people say quantum
it turned out that people could mean
quite different things so i'm going to
begin my talk by clarifying
different levels of quantumness that a
device may exhibit
so the confusion mainly arises from the
fact that we can speak of devices
at many different levels of abstraction
so for example take this laptop computer
one could argue that this laptop
computer is quantum because
the transistor which is sort of like the
main computing engine inside this
computer
operate on quantum principles so you
actually do require quantum physics
to design and engineer transistors
but of course uh in the real world we
don't really
nobody says that laptop computer is a
quantum computer because
at every useful level of abstraction as
a computer
for instance logic boolean logic gates
or random access machine
laptop is a purely classical device
so maybe this is not such a quantum
device and at the other end of the
spectrum
there is a full-fledged quantum computer
which is of course hypothetical at this
time
but in principle we know that quantum
computers
can perform certain tasks much much
faster than classical computers
and in principle we also know that sorry
the quantum computer should not admit an
effective classical description
um and verifying that a quantum computer
is really a quantum computer
is is a challenging task and it's an
interesting research topic
in its own name and we've actually heard
about
that topic multiple times in the
previous workshops
but even before we talk about such more
complex verification protocols
there are certain minimal requirements
that must be met before we can justify
such more serious attempts at
verification so for instance
it should be shown that the machine is
capable of inducing large-scale quantum
behavior like long-range entanglement
and it must be demonstrated that it's
capable of protecting its computation
from environmental noise
and also it should provide some sort of
computational universality
or if that's not possible it should at
least demonstrate
that you can implement an algorithm
which can be used to solve interesting
computational problems
better than any classical algorithm
okay so in the context of dewa emotion
when we're talking about
uh how quantum detai machine is we're
really asking
where in this spectrum uh the da motion
lies
okay so it becomes totally natural to
ask which of these minimal requirements
that the d-rate machine can satisfy
so at the present time it seems that
there is there isn't much evidence put
forth
regarding points b and c but it seems
that we've developed a much better
understanding about point a over the
last year
so this is this will be the main topic
of this talk
um but of course
when we want to study uh the physics of
the ue machine there's an inherent
difficulty
because from an experimental point of
view it's effectively a black box
and what do i mean by that what i mean
is uh presumably there's there's an
intricate engineering going on
in the inside this black box but at the
end of the day when you do experiments
all you get to see is the input and
output to the machine
large
okay
um yeah so that's a good question
uh so it's not completely clear what i
mean by that right
but uh in the computational context
uh what we want is that
at least to to perform something
something that's in principle
cannot be uh performed by a classical
computer we have to show that
there is a long range entanglement
which cannot be described classically so
that's like the minimal requirement
for such devices to have a
superclassical speedo
okay yeah so
uh right so the question is
observing just input and output what
kind of visuals can we possibly hope to
study
right and one answer might be
that well we can maybe study this
question so the question is
we have a machine that solves a certain
computational problem reasonably well so
it's a
we know that it's a ground state problem
for uh using classical using spin glass
and so it sold reasonably well even
though there is no super classical
sphere
and we might ask how is that this
machine is solving this problem
so you know one possibility might be
that this machine is really doing
something
quantum the only quantum tunneling which
means
it's employing um it might be employing
quantum effects
to tunnel through an energy barriers
like this
and escape the local minima in which
case it would be really exciting because
this is the main idea behind
the computational paradigm of d-wave
but on the other hand there's this other
possibility which is that
it might be that the machine is escaping
local minima just with the help of
thermal noise
because the disannealing is performed at
finite temperature
and one would expect that there must be
effects from such thermal noise
okay so these are the two possibilities
and the question
is whether theo is performing quantum
tunneling
or is it performing some kind of
classical thermal annealing
um and one might hope to study this
question by
just looking at the input output
behavior of
theory machines because if quantum
tunneling is indeed
a completely new type of phenomenon
that's completely different from any
classical
processes then one might expect it'll
have
a distinct input output behavior from
those classical processes
so this is basically
as i understand what surgery and friends
did last year so they had a paper in
which they
d waves input output behavior to
two very simple models so one was
quantum monte carlo simulations of
quantum annealing
which was thought to represent quantum
tunneling
and the other model was simulated
annealing
which is kind of like the representative
algorithm for thermal immunity
okay so what they did was they generated
1000 random instances of the t-wave
problem
and then they ran each of these
algorithms so there are three algorithms
the ta machine itself
simulated annealing and quantum monte
carlo simulations
they ran each of these algorithms 1000
times on each of those 1000 instances
and then they record how many times each
algorithm finds
the correct ground state for each
instance okay
so they obtain 1000 success
probabilities for each algorithm
for each instance and then they they
plotted
the scatter plot between the success
probabilities of different algorithms
for instance if you look at this middle
the left
figure this is the scatter plot
depicting the correlation between
delayed success probabilities
and quantum monte carlo success
probabilities
and as you can see there exists a good
correlation between the two because
well in the sense that one instances
where quantum multicolor succeeds
t wave also succeeds on instances where
quantum monte carlo fails the wave also
failed
so it exhibited a good correlation with
the machine
on the other hand you can see that with
simulated annealing
the correlation is slightly worse okay
and and then they also plotted
histograms of
these success probabilities and they
observed that for d
wave and quantum monte carlo
these histograms exhibited clear bimodal
distributions so you can see that
for t and quantum monte carlo there are
two modes distinctively
whereas for simulated annealing the
distribution was clearly unimodal
so these plots so these are histograms
of success probabilities
so we obtain 1000 success probabilities
for toa for instance
we just uh yeah plot them in this
histogram
so the x-axis here is success
probability so we see that
d-wave has some instances where it it
succeeds most of the time
some instances where it fails most of
the time whereas simulated annealing
has instances where it succeeds half the
time
or okay
so at the time um these qualitative
differences
seem to indicate that quantum tunneling
was actually taking place in the machine
and moreover uh dua seemed to work well
on different sets of instances from
classical algorithms so this sort of
became a
source for optimism in the sense that
even if there's no speed up in general
right now
if it's true that dov is performing
quantum tunneling and
uh that d-wave is working well in
different sets of instances
and maybe we can identify that class of
instances for which
p wave is working well and hopefully
speed up in in those
instances okay
so that's sort of the background
so our result is that
we present a new classical model
which accurately describes the input
output behavior of
the d-wave machine on the same data set
as
in serious paper and
this model is extremely simple and
extremely natural
so i think it raises some serious
questions about whether quantum
tunneling is actually taking place in
this machine
because this the existence of this model
sort of renders the situation
somewhat similar to my example of a
laptop computer from the beginning of
the top
where individual components are behaving
quantum mechanically
but on a large scale there's an
effective classical description
so let me tell you what the model is
so our model is basically based on
one thought which is the observation
that the decoherence time of the wave
cubits
is on the order of nanoseconds whereas
the computation time is on the order
microseconds so there are three orders
magnitude difference here
and under such conditions one would
expect that there would be no
quantum entanglement between these two
bits so that's our one assumption we
consider that two bits decorate
immediately
and that there's no entanglement between
the qubits and we consider the simplest
classical model that arises from this
assumption
you can call it bin field model if you
will
so to before i really explain the model
let me just briefly recall the concept
of quantum annealing itself
so inside the d-wave machine we have
this graph structure called the camera
graph
and on each node it's placed a
superconducting flux cubed
and on each edge uh
there's easy couplers uh placed
and then the idea of quantum quantum
annealing is
sorry we uh we prepare this system
in the ground state of this initial
hamiltonian which is
just the x fields uh uniform x fields
on each of these qubits and then
we deform this hamiltonian into our
final hamiltonian which includes the
problem
that we initially wanted to solve so we
do this by
following some kind of schedule like
this so
we get we now get time dependent
hamiltonian which depends on
these unknown curves so you can see that
initially
uh we only have the initial hamiltonian
but then this decreases over time but at
the same time
your uh problem hamiltonian the strength
of your problem here tonya
increases over time and you do this
annealing
at some constant find the temperature
and you hope that
at the by the end of the schedule you
get something
close to the ground state of your
problem antonio
okay so now to to introduce what our
classical model
is uh i just assume that there is no
entanglement
in this between these qubits
and then i'll just translate everything
here word forward
into our classical picture so
instead of using these qubits i'm just
going to put
classical magnets which which can point
in some direction on the xd
plane so you can sort of think of it as
block sphere vectors if you like
and for our hamiltonians
whenever we see an x term we just
replace that by the x component of
our flux corresponding block sphere
vector and
whenever we see a z term we replace it
by the z component
of the corresponding vector
so this is basically our model
is there any question so far okay
so actually sure in the previous talk it
was emphasized that there are other
variations such as a five percent
fluctuation in the coupling strength and
so on
if you're going to compare simulation
against simulation to see
to have hardened instances be hard at
the same time or something
with these fluctuations and coupling
strengths make a big difference
um so i i think it might
so there are cases where these models uh
behave quite sensitively to like
calibration errors
in in the strength of local fields or
coupling couplings
but i think what the d-wave is saying
right now is that
they can basically model all these
control errors
in terms of these needing schedules so
they can translate all those errors
into errors in this in this annealing
schedules and this annealing schedule
might be
you know slightly different for
individual qubits because of control
errors
but that's i think basically
is that right sergio uh that's
that's part of it also that was
particularly important in
rainier which is the data we're looking
at the different animal scandals
that's not so much of an issue in the
ohio room but you know i think
we don't we have a model controller that
much so
i guess maybe the unsecured question is
that
it is going to be quite important but
but for the moment
you know it's it's you know this is a
zeroth order model and
one would probably need to refine it if
one wants to really match uh
you know on every possible input
well he he already said sensitivity so
that's sort of
yeah okay
okay so the rest of the model is the
same so we follow the same
schedule as the d-wave machine we keep
the temperature to be constant compiling
and we just simulate this using the
standard metropolis iron
where at each time say we just pick a
new angle a new random angle
and decide whether to accept this angle
using the metropolis update function
okay and these are our simulation
results
on the same data set as in sergio's
paper
and you can see that our model captures
the input output behavior of
the dva machine extremely well so we see
for instance a clear bimodal signature
in our histogram
and the correlation between our success
probabilities
and d wave success probabilities is
about 0.91 which is slightly higher than
the correlation between d-wave and
quantum monte carlo and you can compare
the figures
if you'd like they behave very similarly
um yeah so these are basically our
experimental results
and if there's any question now about
experiments
take them because now i want to move to
something quite different
somehow you do much much better sorry
right hand side
you're doing much much better
is it here sorry you have a peek at one
here oh i see
yeah sure it's this is kind of like
um well the height of this peak is kind
of
it depends on the parameters that we
choose for instance number of steps
or the system temperature so i think
this is not that important because you
can always tweak these parameters to get
whatever shape you want
but what's important is that you get
this qualitative
picture which is the same as the
machine's behavior
sure and your agreement with monte carlo
is very good as well
that's true which suggests perhaps that
this problem set is not
capable of distinguishing
right so that that would be saying
maybe that uh on these problem sets
quantum monte carlo might not be a truly
quantum model
okay oh by the way i wanted to mention
that the experimental data from series
paper
is probably publicly available on
archive which enabled us to
do this study in the first place and uh
you know of course sergio and
charles reynolds and especially matthias
troyer have been very helpful in
sharing their ideas and their more
recent data so i want to thank them for
that
now i'd like to proceed to the next big
question
which is so now that we have this
extremely simple model
how could it be that this this simple
model reproduces what was thought to be
quantum tunneling
okay so to answer this question i'm
going to
study our our model for a more
algorithmic viewpoint
and i'm going to do this by making a
very simple
and i'm going to start this by making a
very simple observation which is
basically that
our model when you remove this x field
effectively becomes simulated annealing
okay so my
slogan for this is our model minus
transverse field equal to
the milling and a way to see this
is you just remove this field x still
and then you look at the metropolis
update function
so now that i remove this term all i get
here is
p of t over temperature times the energy
difference between
the new configuration and the old
configuration
and this guy here is going to be
important because if you think about our
model
so in our model the temperature is
constant right
and this b of t increases over time
which means this quantity monotonically
increases over time
in simulated annealing this b of t
is always one but temperature decreases
over time
right so from the perspective of this
function
these two processes will have exactly
the same behavior
which means that our model without the
transverse field
is exactly equivalent to simulated
annealing
so if it's the case that our model
describes a d-wave machine but simulator
annealing doesn't
then this transverse field must be
precisely the reason
so what is the role of transverse field
so basically the role of transverse
field i claim
is that it provides a gradation in
in the magnitude of z components of the
vectors
so what do i mean by that so imagine
you don't have transfer scale so you
don't have this x still
then your spins will always want to
align in the direction
of the z field that they're feeling
regardless of their
strength right so whether you're in a
weak
z field or strong z field you'll always
want to just align with the field
whereas when you have the x field
spins that that are under the influence
of stronger z fields
really have more z components because
now they're also getting pulled towards
this x direction
and if you have a stronger z field
then you'll be able to resist this x
field more strongly so you'll have more
z component
so here this is a snapshot of our
simulation
with and without x field so you can see
that when there is no x field
most pins uh point either in
plus z or minus z directions but when
there
is x field they can have various
different angles
okay so for those of you who are
familiar with the spectral graph theory
this is kind of reminiscent of
cuts and eigenvectors because to look
for good cuts
we uh employ
some kind of a more predated object
okay so if the previous slide was too
confusing all i wanted to say was that
it's really
this this transverse field completely
changes the phenomenon
it becomes a completely different
process so what does it become what is
it really doing
so to understand this let's try a
different picture so now i have this
time axis here um it goes from zero to
one
and we have a type excuse me
we have a time dependent hamiltonian so
at time zero we have h of zero h of one
and now i want to ask
uh what are the local minima of
the these hamiltonians
at some fixed time t so for now let's
forget about time evolution
let's let's think about this this
hamiltonian h of zero
okay so h of zero was just a hamiltonian
in which
there was only x field for every qubit
so this hamiltonian obviously can only
have
one local minimum which is every spin
pointing in the x direction
so i'm going to depict this local
minimum by this time
and and then i'll think about
uh this guy over here at the other end
so we have h01 which is our problem
using hamiltonian
and what are the local minimum that
hamiltonian
well it's a complicated hamiltonian and
we would expect that
there will be many local minima so i'll
depict them by this many dots
and you can sort of imagine doing the
same thing for all these intermediate
hamiltonians
and if i do that i get a picture that
looks like this so
sorry so is this picture okay so all i
mean by this
is uh if i if i slice this picture at
some time t
the intersection these intersections
will represent the local minima of the
hamiltonian at that time point
okay so
what
so what i really mean is physical
equilibrium of this hamiltonian
so i mean a state in which
you basically don't want to move
does that make better sense or no
yes
so is this clear to everyone or more
questions
okay so
i claim that
when we run a simulation of our model
what what happens in this landscape
is well you always start in this in this
initial state
but then as as your time evolved
the system you're following one of these
paths so initially there is only one
path to follow
but eventually you'll have many more
possibilities
so when you run this at zero temperature
you'll always follow one particular path
when you do this at finite temperature
you're kind of wiggling around this path
and you might get into a different path
every time
and uh more importantly you might get
these thermal jumps where if you have
paths that are not really connected to
your
your current path but sufficiently close
by
then you might jump to that pad
which was which might not have been
accessible to you uh
in the absence of noise okay so you
might
the next time you do this you might get
into a different path so you can see
these
thumber jumps occurring here
okay uh
so yeah my point is that this
thermal jump is the effect of
having the computation run at a finite
temperature instead of zero temperature
so there's another quick observation
that that i can make
um so let's look at this annealing
schedule for a second
so i'm going to cut this schedule here
at the red line
if you look at the schedule after this
red line
then you realize that this this x field
has grown so weak by the time that we
can effectively ignore it
so if i just remove this and do the
simulation
and i'm not going to notice any
difference in the behavior of the model
so this expert is really not doing
anything
but then we know that when there's no x
field
our model is simulated on healing
so i can say that
in the second half all i'm doing is
simulated annually
but also it's not just any simulated
annealing it simulated the kneeling
that didn't start from the beginning
right it started from the middle because
in the first half i'm doing something
completely different
so if you think about simulated
annealing it's an algorithm that
initially you really aggressively search
your
search space but then as as time goes by
you become more and more like
local search right so this is exactly
what happens
so by this time your simulated annealing
has already become so much like
like local search and you can just think
of it as local search
which can only only flip a few spins at
once
okay and in the first part we know that
it's it was choosing one of those paths
in a probabilistic manner with the help
of thermal noise of course
so with with this observation now coming
back to this picture
we we have a much clearer understanding
what's going on here
so we saw that in the first part we're
just picking one of these pets
randomly and
uh or uh equivalently we can we can
think of the think of the first part as
picking one of these local minima
of the hamiltonian at this cutting point
probabilistically because
you may follow different paths but
you'll eventually get into one of these
guys
okay and then after that we know that
all that's happening is local search
what does it mean
so that means uh if if at this point
if you get into one of those points
which are
sufficiently close to your true ground
state then you're basically done there
because local search will always get you
there
if you get into something that's far
away from the ground state then you're
doomed
local search can do nothing about that
okay so it's as though there are some
there's some good points among these
local minima of
the hamiltonian at this point and
all your job is to try to get into one
of these good points
and then you'll find the ground state
so in that sense we can say that if all
this
algorithmically interesting is going on
in the first part
and second part doesn't really matter in
that sense
so if you started in the path
if you stayed on the path that started
at h of zero and
you managed to stay on it would you be
guaranteed to be in the
global minimum no no it might not be
connected
so i mean you're saying so if that was
true basically um
you just run this simulation at zero
temperature and you'll always get into
the correct solution right i mean is
that
the case so if that was the case then
there would have been there wouldn't
have been any meaning to
doing any of this because there would be
a classical algorithm that always finds
the questions
is not so well defined it might it might
branch and then what does it mean
sorry but if you want to do
if you want to do the actual quantum
adiabatic algorithm that you would like
to run
that's that's right but then why is such
a big photo
i think if you have access to the whole
space of course it will be connected
and this is a real severe truncation to
help dispose of problems
so the path we are restricted to
variational manifold
product states there will be some
there'll be some variational manifold
that may be a little bit larger or a lot
larger
okay so
uh one question that arises here
is that empirically if we
we count the number of local minima that
we see here
at this point we only see like 20 of
them
so and also it's it's not the case that
those 20 local minima
are reached with equal probability
usually there are
few of them they're strongly preferred
so this becomes a complete complete
mystery in this in computational sense
because now it looks like
we're solving this 108-bit problem
and this model is solving this problem
pretty well
but it's solving this by exploring a
very small search space
right there are two two to the 108
possible solutions
but it kind of looks like we're finding
the right solution by just just
considering
like a dozen of them right so how can it
be possible
um so this is a very curious thing
so in order to understand this we we
looked at actually
what happens physically at one of these
branching points where you're you're
choosing between two paths
and this is the picture we get so these
are
basically a graphical representation of
108
uh two bits of qa1 and
excuse me and the black dots here
represent the difference between the two
pads
so i took the first branching point of
one of the instances that were used in
our experiments
and the black dots represent the
difference between those two paths
and what do i mean by that what i mean
is i take one of the path
i flip all this all the black spins then
i get the other path
okay so in that sense it's the
difference between the two paths
uh so what is it saying
that's saying that uh
uh the choice that's being made at this
branching point
is really the relative orientation
between the white cluster
and the black cluster
right and so this is the first branching
point of this
this instance if you look at the later
branching points
you basically basically get the same
phenomenon but
with smaller and smaller clusters
so what is the significant significance
of this
excuse me
sorry so uh yeah what's the significance
of this denominator
the significance is it's it's kind of
telling us
that this particular choice of graph
structure by d
wave is playing a very important role in
this
algorithmic phenomenon right
because um
so we saw that so everything that was
interesting about
about this procedure was happening
really in the first part
and in the first part we see that what's
what's happening is choosing relative
orientation between these
clusters but then
this if you look at this graph it has
structure
that kind of allows us to view this as
a 2d lattice of 16 supernodes when you
coarse grain
like this so
it kind of suggests it provides a sense
in which
you can think of this problem
as effectively having the problem size
of 16
which is the number of super nodes
rather than the number of spins which
was 108
so that's the question that's being
raised here
and if this is really the case
then even though d-wave or other
heuristic methods like simulated
annealing
are being quite successful at solving
this problem at this
ending 100 108
we can conjecture that it will be the
case that
when the number of supernodes becomes
sufficiently large
they will all sort of suffer from
combinatorial exploding
so what what matters is not this n but
the number of supernovas
m and this intuition seems to be
confirmed by
recent experiments by renault era
in which they show that as problem size
growth the running time of g-wave
scales exponentially in the problem size
okay so now uh trying to finish this
talk we finally come back to our
story of quantum tunneling versus
classical formal effects
so our findings clearly suggest that um
at least on this particular regime where
we consider random instances of
the dva problem the t-wave input output
behavior can be explained
just by classical thermal effect okay so
so um of course this brings us back to
this picture of laptop
because now it seems that there's a
classical model that effectively
describes the large scale behavior of
this machine
in this particular regime and this also
poses a
clear challenge for doa and proponents
of doa
which is to identify a different regime
in which they might be able to show that
the machine is
really doing something quantum and
cannot be described by a simple
classical model like ours
i guess surgery is working in that
direction um
and before i really finish i want to say
it just
does it say microsoft error reporting
yes yes
great
i totally expected this
i'm saying
you know what to do yeah
okay okay yeah so before i finish i just
want to say a little bit about recent
developments because recently there was
this paper
by pinji era in which they
propose an experiment which which they
claim to refute our model
it's a different type of experiment than
what we're doing
so i'm going i'm just going to give a
natural version of this experiment
so basically the main idea of this this
experiment
is they turned down the strength of your
problem hamiltonian so initially
normally your your leaning schedule
looks like this so the problem
hamiltonian increases
uh following this solid blue curve but
now they turn it down
so instead of doing this they follow
this body curve
or they turn it further down and you
know it becomes even weaker
and they basically they observe the
machine's
response to this kind of change and they
report that our model does not reproduce
the machine's behavior when the final
hamiltonian is very weak
like this compared to the x field
which is strong
uh so but this is
this is kind of strange because
you can see that as the final
hamiltonian is it's turned down
the effect of thermal noise becomes more
and more significant
because so i'm not sure if you can see
but there's this
gray dotted line here which is which
sort of represents the system
temperature
so you can see that when your
hamiltonian is really weak
everything is really dominated but
dominated by thermal noise
and especially by the time your
hamiltonian even
kicks in your x field is completely dead
okay so it's kind of like moving into
a more and more classical regime
but this is the region that they're
saying that our model doesn't reproduce
the machine's behavior
which of course brings us to an
important question which is
you know is our model too quantum to
reproduce serious behavior
but that's not the point so nonetheless
so i did some preliminary
experiments over the last couple of days
and it seems that we can
under a reasonable assumption on
calibration errors and so on
i can make our model reproduce the
machine's behavior
so that's good but that's really not the
point i wanted to touch upon
a much more fundamental question here
which is
is it really fair to ask such questions
to our model
because if you think about our model
it's really like a zeroth order model
in the sense that we made no attempt to
model anything
beyond the basic computational concept
which is just quantum annealing
with no entanglement okay so it's
it's certainly a case that you cannot
expect this simple model to explain
everything about the
about the machine because the model is
extremely simple
the machine is extremely complicated so
if if somebody really spends time and
effort to find
an example where the model and the
machine diverge
then almost certainly he he will be able
to do that
but that's really not the point you know
if you really want
a model that explains everything then
there is no other way
but to just open the black box and model
the inner workings of the black box
so the the important question here
should be
can you demonstrate some computationally
meaningful quantum phenomena
like quantum tunneling that our model
is not able to describe so this is the
question that t-wave and
should be focusing on
and uh in in that light i
i want to finish this talk by
emphasizing once more that
the point of this talk is to is not to
argue that
pwave is classical our intention here is
to
um to critically assess dva's position
and provide them with scientific
feedback
and at this time our results indicate
that duaf hasn't made
a good case for their quantumness thank
you
for more questions for someone
so although you didn't want to tell us
um i'm surprised that
in in the ap mention of vinci tower they
they
attempted to recover their signature by
having some additional
phasing to releasing spirits rather than
all three scales
um you say that you just need a
collaboration
sure so
let's see yeah let me just tell you a
very high level idea
so i think in all these phenomena um
i think this is also related to what
serious talked about a little bit
what's what's kind of being important is
that
our model responds very differently to
couplings
and to local fields because couplings
are sort of like second order thing and
local feels the first order
so when spins when spins have small
angles
local fields will be will feel much
stronger to the spin than the couplings
right so this is basically the reason
that our model does not reproduce for
instance
uh daniel leaders experiments
but the thing is this is also very
sensitive to
the the precision of calibration between
the local fields and the couplings in
the sense that
so you're implementing this this curve
in which you you increase the strength
of
both of those uh hamiltonian terms
right but uh
if it's the case that uh the local
fields and couplings
don't quite follow the same schedule but
they're
sort of like wiggling around and you
know qualitatively they're doing
they're following this increasing curve
but they're not very accurate
then
the our our model's behavior which
doesn't reproduce
the experiments is not very robust
to this kind of errors i mean is
when you introduce these errors our
model's behavior completely changes
so it's very sensitive to
the calibration in this annealing
schedule between couplings and local
fields
and this is basically so just just to
factor somehow the way you can think
about it is in order to find
a position of disagreement a point of
disagreement between our model and
ebay what they had to do was look at
this very sensitive region you know
it's not like they could find it very
easily they had to have to
go to a very you know
a very particular kind of point but that
point is extremely sensitive to noise
you know so so now it was not a robust
example but one that was extremely
sensitive
so now that you're there you're going to
have to come up with a noise to see
but i guess my question was the
following i agree it's a very sensitive
point but
but if there was any signal there at all
suggesting that
we should play it was the same result as
you get with
simulated annealing over icing space
and so the attempts in that paper to
explain the square
was an artificial dephasis
so i'd like to understand you know you
had this conjecture about the effective
problem size
being closer to m equals 16 than 108 and
it seems like the reason you
you might conjecture this is because you
study this classical model that you have
right but uh but as you proposed it this
classical model is just to
try to reproduce the input output output
behavior
not necessarily the inner workings of
the device
so do you have additional reasons for
believing why
no no it was a heuristic argument in the
sense that we know that the input
so so yeah what i meant to say was to
the extent that our model captures the
algorithmic behavior of d-ray
e-wave also will have this problem
um yeah so i wasn't claiming more than
that really
sorry i guess great um
this is a question for you or for
someone anyway
suppose you've had a really good quantum
annealing
device at the perfect cubits
whatever cube kind of qubits you want
and so
whatever temperature profile you want
anything like that
but with the same general annealing
schedule
i know that adiabatic computing
in in of all kinds is universal for bqp
but not not necessarily annealing on a
graph
with switching from x couplings to z
couplings that's very restricted do you
expect
in this idealized circumstance which is
not about d-wave anymore
a grover class speed up more than grover
class
uh i think this this you know
it's a unique issue okay
i mean this this this whole thing it's a
very good question i mean this is uh
this is something that came up back in
2000
when eddie fary and companies published
their papers sort of
preliminarily talking about idiotic
quotes